I've never been good at talking.
When I was 13 and I would talk to boys
that I like on the phone,
I would have a list
of questions and topics
that I could refer to if the conversation lulled.
Which was like, 100% of the time.
Um..
Well, uh..
"Mrs. Michael Esmeralda heart heart heart."
Wait, no..
No that's--that's just a doodle,
that's n--it's not a real...
a real topic..
Anna, you idiot!
(slap)
(sobs)
And often, I'll find myself in a conversation
where I really don't have anything to say or add,
but it feels awkward to just exist there,
so I'll just nod and smile
and laugh really loud.
And look, it's not like I don't have
opinions or things to say,
it's just that in most conversations
I like being the listener, you know?
But unfortunately, this has led to
not being able to keep conversations going
if it's completely up to me
to keep them going..
So uh..
You like cats?
Uh, you asked me that already.
Right...
Alright.
So do you?
But I've realized
over the course of many many conversations
in Los Angeles,
that the only thing you really have to do
is to ask people about themselves.
So where were you
on the 25th of January?
You mean today?
(scoffs)
Exactly.
I worked for a little bit,
uh..
did some grocery shopping..
So you cook, huh?
Yeah, I mean...
it's much cheaper than eating out
all the time...
What are some of your favorite recipes?
Oh,
I've recently been introduced to quinoa.
All it really takes
is to find common ground on one thing.
And for me, that, most of the time,
that's a love for cats.
Or like, have a genuine interest in something that
someone's revealed to you.
And then the conversation just..
flourishes.
And I don't know why it's taken me
so long to figure out, but...
hope it helps.
Vague movie quote and reference
to an obscure indie film in the 70s.
Ooh, recognition of said subtle reference,
and the preceding movie quote
right back at ya.
(nervous giggle)
(giggling builds)
(subsides)
I'd like to say thank you to Audible
for sponsoring today's episode.
And the most requested accent
was a southern woman.
So here we go.
[clears throat]
(Southern accent) Ah'd like to thank audible.com
fer sponsoring this here episode.
You can go to audible.com/anna
and get a free audiobook o' yer choice.
They have over 150,000 titles
to choose from,
Hallelujah.
Deep voice offscreen: Praise Jesus!
Currently, ah'm listenin' to Gone Girl
by Gillian Flynn
because ah would love frame my husband
fer my murder.
(giggles)
You can get that,
or another free audiobook o' yer choice
over at audible.com/anna.
That is audible.com/anna.
(normal) I'm Anna Akana.
You stay awesome.